hey guys it's Tuesday yeah
time for another sidetrack yeah what's
going on you got anything on a list or
anything we have to talk about what the
kitty did last night yeah there's a
weird thing woke up in the middle of
night around 3:00 what the hell is going
on within danced on Glassdoor now run up
she's fighting with a cat on the other
side of the glass that cat goes running
off the little orange damn tabby cat
look like a little orange tomcat this is
the craziest okay so I never heard her
to make that noise yeah Pookie I mean
she wakes us up old sound like jumping
on us being like hey play or hey I'm out
of treats or whatever but I woke up well
I was awake already because I woke up
and for some reason I was like really
really thirsty I'd even been like
dreaming about going in the kitchen and
getting like a big glass of ice water
and then bringing into the thing and
then having to refill it cuz I kept
drinking it I don't know why I was
dreaming that but I woke up and I was
really thirsty and it was like quarter
to three and then all of a sudden I yeah
I hear pokey going like wow and I was
like she never makes that noise and
olenin like what that's right she was
calling somebody she was calling and
then we're all I was like what the [ __ ]
why should I was like is she alright was
she making that noise and so then he was
like well there must be something out
there because he saw that he could see
her like under the curtain like yes
sittin looking out the sliding glass
door yeah and then he was like well
there must be something out there so I
was like okay whatever so then I laid
back down and then like about five or
ten minutes later all of a sudden we
hear later yeah yeah he's fine and I was
like [ __ ] it like because again I've
never heard Pookie hit ya or anything
like Beijing when they play a Beijing
hisses at her all the time it was she
doesn't use and she doesn't care she's
just like whatever I'm gonna whack you
in the butt you know I'm cute but she
doesn't hiss at other cats but she made
this like horrible noise and I was like
holy [ __ ] and so we got up and then we
look out the thing and she's just she
was like hissing and stuff missionary to
sex yeah like that and it was that
little like there was a little orange
tie fight to get through the glass yeah
she's like wrinkled kicked that cat's
ass yeah I can't would have kicked her
ass
yeah he was bigger than her yeah well
and well that solved the mystery because
of a couple was it two or three nights
ago I woke up another night and we
thought we heard a cat crying outside
like to Beijing get left outside that's
like who is that it's like didn't sound
like you can see him there though and we
couldn't see anything so we felt well it
must be just a neighbor cat that's like
wandering around looking for [ __ ] but
it's like holy crap man so it's like I
didn't even hardly get any sleep because
she because she scared the [ __ ] out of
me [ __ ] hissing and crap and then she
sat there for like ages like watching
for that cat to come back but I guess he
never did and so it's like I don't know
I'm kind of scared about her going out
of the fortune chick because what if
that cat comes back and like beats up
our I hope not I mean I guess he only
comes around like in the middle of he
bags like 3:00 in the morning
he knows cats are here yeah that's what
he's like he smells like lady cats I
guess even though they're both fixed I
wanted to show you guys something this
is my yearbook all right from the first
in the five or six when I was up on a
DMZ in Korea back in 91 I want to show
you something see there's this guy in
here where is it where is it I don't
know back yes that's it right there
let's see that name right there it says
van vac yes all right and I'm up here
[Laughter]
right there I got a call or a message
last night from a friend of mine who was
in this unit I'm not gonna name his name
cuz he's working for a government agency
I'm not sure which one it is right now
but he's been talking to van vac yes
ma'am Becky's been locked up for about
five or six years he got sentenced for
20 years conspiracy to murder a DEA
agent what he had been doing he did 20
years in the army [ __ ] ran a Sniper
school [ __ ] was a high ranking NCO was
a drill sergeant did his twenty came out
of service and joined a band of
international mercenaries
guys from the German army the Polish
army guys from the Russian army this
group of mercenaries were working for
Colombian drug lord as bodyguards
assassins and they were training a narco
army
well his client I had to get something
done evidently and to get this mission
done they were gonna he'll kill this DEA
agent somehow the thing fell through
they all got locked up well the buddy
who was in the same unit evidently did a
bunch of interviews with him you know I
mean cuz it's best if you're gonna talk
to some guys is you get France old
friends you know from this the military
and government [ __ ] and [ __ ] weird
mercenary stuff is a scene it's a
community special operations and
intelligence and [ __ ] so a lot of times
these guys have friends old army friends
that are still working foreign agencies
they'll bring him forward and talk to
him you know get him to tell his story
anyway he got 20 years for this he'll be
out though for about ten years from now
10-15 years they're gonna make a movie
about him and some documentaries about
the [ __ ] that him and his international
his his group of international
mercenaries of what they were doing it's
a wild [ __ ] man it's [ __ ] really wild
[ __ ] that's pretty crazy cuz you see in
a place like Colombia these drug lords a
lot of times either have partial or
total control over the damn Colombian
government they're almost kind of merged
with it all right
so from our point of view they'd be
criminals but from that point of view
from the point of view of the Colombian
drug lords are more like secret agents
[ __ ] you know I mean they go down and
[ __ ] kill judges and do all kinds of
[ __ ] [ __ ] that you see in the
newspapers there guys like man vacuous
creating those narco armies that's where
they come from they're paying him
$700,000 per hit damn yeah yeah yeah
yeah he's been down there for a long
time and evidently like just little
stuff you're talking about
thousand dollars just for like little
stuff so he was making millions huh I
can see why that would be tempting yeah
and and you know the missions that
you're getting put on by these cartels
you're just hitting other cartels enemy
cartels scumbags usually yes orally or
enforcing discipline inside the narco
army because you got a whole army of
criminals you know you can't be nice to
them to get them to follow the rules
terror is an effective tool of
management so you know they break the
rules they do something when they're not
supposed to do you know do something
with it weren't told to do it or they
steal or whatever you got to go down
there and cut their faces off or
something you know I mean torture him to
death and that's the kind of [ __ ] he was
doing sometimes you gotta cut a
[ __ ] space sometimes get a cut
of [ __ ] face off well how are
you gonna negotiate with [ __ ] an army
how are you gonna command an entire army
of criminals yeah without doing stuff
like that you have to do that kind of
[ __ ] and that's so you're gonna make a
movie about him he's [ __ ] like a
real-life John wig yeah wonder how long
that's gonna be before they actually get
a movie about him going they're making
it right now identify trying to get
according to the guy that that told me
yeah that they're making a movie and a
series of documentaries about him and
his team because they're a team they're
a cat they were a cadre of ex-military
guys that served as bodyguards and
trainers you know and torpedoes also
assassins
that's gonna be interested man for the
record I know vamp Bacchus he was a good
soldier real good guy but I haven't seen
him for a long long time and unto thee
that [ __ ] not an international mercenary
national mercenary I don't work for drug
cartels really I haven't I haven't seen
from Vecchia since the nine we would
have a lot more money if you and I
wouldn't be doing a podcast right be out
working
[Laughter]
he didn't know where I was yeah Prada
gotten a call but anyway I wouldn't do
it no it just seems like yeah it's a lot
of money and I can see that would be
tempting but I just I don't know it
seems like it would be too he had been
he had been a soldier for 20 years yeah
and retired okay it's it's very
difficult to reincorporate into a
[ __ ] civilian life what are you gonna
do go flip burgers yeah yeah what do you
[ __ ] do yeah you're gonna go work for
somebody you know or you're gonna sit
around collect your [ __ ] money he
wanted to go back to work so who's he
gonna go work for somebody who's gonna
[ __ ] pay me a bunch of money and send
him on an interesting missions and
someone who reward him with good-looking
girls and give him a bunch of power and
that look he's probably living like a
king down there yeah yeah he would
straight Bubba Fett yeah yeah bonus
points if he was actually wearing the
outfit that would have been really cool
I'm sure this is the first time he went
to prison I think he did five years
before that too I think I have to go
back and look I just heard I just you
know there's stuff out there on Van back
yes but I haven't um I haven't looked at
it yet I just listened to what I was
told
yeah last night yeah if you just told me
like the guy who told me been working
with him I'm not working with him but
working on him yeah you know I mean he's
a friend of ours
he'd been interviewing him and talking
to him for the people he works with he's
a good guy yeah okay so he'd been
talking to him for years we couldn't
tell me until till the sentencing and
all trial [ __ ] was over right so that
right right they couldn't tell me yeah
but he says now me I wanted to tell you
but I can tell you him yeah yeah yeah
yeah any good yeah he choices he's wild
wild [ __ ] man [ __ ] hardcore
that is pretty crazy yeah oh I heard the
door creaks Luke that means Pookie come
in here so um I don't know maybe we'll
do a show about Van vacuous when more
stuff goes and we'll get on top of that
because that's a trick crime show and I
know I know two guys another guy it's a
good man
yeah good man that's pretty crazy um
just uh he went for the gold I mean for
the [ __ ] gold oh look at Polk there's
your butt oh yeah um your your back
belly button yeah what's up little Buki
you saving us from that like bad orange
Katie let that snake like flip it out
waking us up at 3:00 in the morning you
little brat yes I'm gonna be falling
asleep early early because I think we
were as we watched like I tried to watch
more of the season of hoarders because I
was talking to people and you day
weren't as good as the first three
well it's man they really blew their wad
right out of the gate didn't it it's
like those three it's you can tell that
they're trying to like do like a
different type of hoarder in each one
because the one of the ones that we were
watching last night was one of those
people that they pick up everything like
out of the garbage or they like buy
things they think sell this I can sell
this I can sell this now she did
actually sell things and that was how
she made her living but she had three
houses yo in Florida and all of them
were full of crap and it was just like
the whole [ __ ] situation was [ __ ]
and then the one that we started
watching and that I couldn't stay awake
anymore so I like fell asleep in the
middle of it was three dudes like two of
them were brothers and then one of them
was a friend of theirs and they were all
hoarders like they all lived within like
a couple miles of each other or they
lived next door or something and all of
them work order so there's like oh now
it's like now it's like a triple threat
like they're gonna have to clean out all
these old farts but I'll watch the rest
of the [ __ ] [ __ ] tonight probably but
uh yep there's kitties but again yeah
she just can't stop herself she's like
she's an exhibition well she likes to
chew on things that's what it is she's
not in a gym on purpose putting her butt
in the camera it's just she likes to
chew on the edge of the desk yeah and to
do that she's got a bad note and to do
that she has to yeah all right so what
we're gonna wrap up today's sidetrack
show have
rest of your Tuesday go check out our
Atlanta child murders show which I just
posted this morning almost three hours
long so go check that out if you haven't
already and we'll talk to you guys again
tomorrow